are we gonna get the moment that's
really iconic in the in the comics where
miss marvel meets captain marvel are we
gonna get a little you and brie larson
meeting in this series or are we waiting
for the film you're asking a lot of good
questions here man yeah thank you what's
your relationship like with brie i
understand that she called you to kind
of talk you through what it would be
like to join a marvel film what was it
like having that mentor it's crazy i
have pictures of her on my wall and now
i have her phone number so should we
call her right now
absolutely not let's facetime her let's
see if she picks up
my phone is i don't even know where it
is is that it right there that's it
don't have it memorized you didn't
memorize brie's phone number oh god i
don't even know what mine is um
no but she's been super supportive and
you know having a figure like a brie
larson kind of hold your hand throughout
all of this and and tell you she's going
through the same things that you are is
just crazy the fact that the people i
relate to now are marvel actors and and
they're like my peers it's weird
so your brother told us about your
avengers party
he did yes and even though it will be a
distraction from your studies and there
will be lot of haram going on there
kamala
we have decided
to let you go
really really real yes but there are
special conditions
your abu will drive you there and he
will go inside with you for two hours
and as far as your dressing goes
i have a surprise for you
the hulk i feel like you and kamala are
on very similar paths did you feel that
while you were shooting this 100 her
getting her powers and me getting this
part went hand in hand completely i've
heard from your some of your co-stars
that uh you can recite the first five
minutes of iron man i can't is that true
i'll be the first like three lines okay
are you driving me to court martial i
feel like you're gonna pull over and
stuff me what is this
i'm like so nervous right now and he's
like no
they're
oh my god you're doing great you're
doing great i swear i can do this i can
do the first ten minutes i just am so
overwhelmed with too many emotions right
now i mean this is your first
big like
lead role premiere like how are you
feeling right now aside from nervous are
you able to take this in at all no
it's it's it's so much bigger than me
and and you know we're finally being
able to celebrate something that we've
been working on for two years and the
show for me is this character has been a
part of my life for for like
god
six seven years now and it just means
the world that i can finally you know
share what i what i saw when i picked up
those comics the first time yeah i mean
i i've read the comics as well and i'm
sure they resonated with you in a
different way than they resonated with
me but what is it like for you being
able to bring an authentic experience
like all of yourself to this role and
not have to like hold anything back you
know what i mean like being able to say
like oh actually at dinner you know our
family might be more like this we would
do it you know this way or this is
always a thing that you know this is
always a relationship that was really
strong with us yeah i was super
encouraged by you know our all our
producers and directors to kind of put
as much of our real life into into our
characters and make them as specific and
as authentic as possible and i
definitely just went to work and was
totally playing myself in a large set
with all these fun toys around me so
yeah it was fun as a fan of the mcu what
was your favorite easter egg because the
first two episodes there's i don't want
to ruin anything for anyway but there's
a lot going on where there's a lot of
different like references to the films
and the shows what was one of your
favorite little drops in there
there's there's an avenger con there's
like a card that says america's ass it's
hilarious i love that one
[Music]
foreign